yo creo que el primer reto que tiene
gustavo petro es el reto económico
porque como bien dijiste hay millones de
personas en la pobreza en colombia
después del primer pues del golpe que
significó la pandemia tiene todavía el
desempleo en dos dígitos y va a tener
que luchar contra la inflación que es un
fenómeno mundial y que en este momento
por supuesto también está afectando a
colombia por otro lado lamentablemente
el panorama de seguridad es bastante
preocupante con el aumento
de la presencia tanto del clan del golfo
como en las dos disidencias que en este
momento están posicionadas en algunos
lugares de colombia sobre todo del sur
de colombia del pacífico nariñense y por
supuesto la guerrilla de la ln con la
que gustavo petro ya está tratando de
abrir un camino para el cómo retomar la
negociación que se suspendió en 2019
después del atentado que esta guerrilla
hizo en la escuela general santander